hey guys how's it going Justine and
today we are testing out the new iPhone
8 plus camera I've got all three colors
right here so you guys can take a look
because I've you have to show you guys
the different colors this is the Space
Gray and we have the 8 silver and the
beautiful rose gold which is mine now
the iPhone 8 is out has been dubbed the
fastest phone on the market currently
which is pretty excited because you guys
might know I'm a little bit of a fan
we're Nev testing out the video and the
photos and I've got the help of some of
my friends back here it's uh ed and
Jenna they're getting ready for their
slow-mo 1080p shots with a new iPhone A+
camera
[Music]
so the first thing we're gonna test out
is the back camera we're gonna be using
something new portrait lighting features
so let's test those out
[Music]
let's take this photo of Jenna and we
can go in and I can show you guys the
difference here's the natural light
switch into studio light adds a lot more
light on her face contour adds some more
shadows to her face and some on her body
as well and the stage light basically
removes the entire background and makes
it seem like she's in a studio the stage
light mono makes the entire photo black
and white
[Music]
these photo filters aren't anything new
when you go in to edit your photos in
the camera app but one thing that I
think a lot of people might overlook is
this when you go in to adjust the
lightness and the darkness and the color
in the black and white if you click this
little thing right here this will take
you in to be able to adjust even more
finer details a lot of people rely on
third-party editing apps but really you
can do pretty much everything right here
inside of the camera app those previous
photos weren't taken in portrait mode
but this one was you can tap the
portrait mode button at the top if you
want to remove the blurred background or
if you like it you can tap it again to
add it back on that little magic wand up
at the top will do some auto
enhancements for you if you just want to
cross your fingers and hope for the best
you can always go into any of those
portrait mode photos and edit any of the
studio lighting to change them on the
fly wait see if you can get the look
screen though of us taking this you want
me to do it armed you know but like this
filming this screen
cool let's look and see what we've got
slides open it's super Craigs
slide so let's go get a slide pick one
of the new things with a plus camera is
this optical image stabilization which
also helps out with the front and the
back camera so if you're feeling a
little shaky and a little crazy your
pictures will come out way more smooth
and crisp now let's see if we can do
some slo-mo down the slide
slo-mo playground
[Music]
today I'm gonna slo-mo you break it just
go fast I don't think you're gonna super
slow-mo whip your hair back and forth
yes
[Music]
all right yeah
are you trying to be sexy not really
just I want more carefully
[Music]
dad you wanna do a slow-mo hair flip
I got a lot of questions for people
asking how do I change the video quality
settings
it's simple go into settings camera and
here you can change the video settings
from 4k 60 to 30 to 24 and so on and
also the slo-mo from 1080p at 240 to
1080 120 let's first test out 4k at 60
frames and now here's what it looks like
slowed down 50% this is normal 240 and
now here's what it looks like slow down
25% looks pretty good I think I'm a fan
I think my junk could use a little her
here's 4k at 30 frames a second and here
is 4k at 24 frames a second lets us out
some 4k footage from the back facing
camera and I'm not gonna touch the audio
as it comes out of this camera is what
you guys are gonna see next we're gonna
hear it this is the back camera and
we're shooting right now at 4k 60 frames
a second which is new to the iPhone 8
Plus which gives you a very smooth
effect I don't typically like to shoot
my vlogs in 60 frames a second because
it does make you a little bit dizzy but
it will allow you to slow down your
footage you can also get slow-mo and not
have to shoot at 120 here it is look at
this let's slow down the 60 frames a
second landed it here we are
friend facing camera iPhone 8 plus now
the problem shooting here is there's
very harsh shadows and there's also some
very bright lights it's gonna be
interesting to see how it handles this
Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
bringing my okay so what we need to do
now is we have to trust stack these your
whole yeah so fan them out sort of like
this I think I made a really big mistake
by taking this project on now the most
difficult thing when testing out
multiple cameras is some cameras perform
better in different lighting some
perform different in different
situations so it's really hard to tell
which is gonna be the best so we've got
here is the iPhone 8 camera this is the
Google pixel this is the essential phone
Samsung Galaxy s8 Samsung Galaxy Note 8
and the iPhone 8 plus fairly sure what I
got myself into they keep turning off
every time I try doing some pretty harsh
lighting conditions the shadows are
pretty intense places here it's really
bright and it's also a little windy too
it's a vibe
just take the picture and file don't
move
well I mean it can like move a little
I'm just I just need you to be there in
one position
okay ready that's good now keep that
pose ready past romance is worth telling
me I just crash
[Music]
look like watch me
so now we're gonna suss out the portrait
mode on the iPhone 8 plus and you live
focus on the Samsung movie
[Music]
switching phones let's turn the blur all
the way the interesting thing with live
focus on the Samsung is when you're
taking it it looks like absolute trash
like if I don't even know how the
pictures gonna look good but then when
you go into the preview mode it looks
incredible
[Music]
both the iPhone 8 portrait mode and the
note 8 live focus took incredible photos
it is really hard to choose which one I
like the best but I feel like out of
this set of photos I may like the note 8
just a little bit more and you have much
more control over that degree of blur on
the note 8 than you do on the iPhone A+
but in some of the iPhone photos they
looked better but then in some of the
note 8 photos they looked better it
really I think depends on the situation
anyway let's test out the front-facing
selfie camera on all of these phones
I would have to say out of this set
probably my favorite shot is on the
pixel it picked up a lot of great
contrasts in the backgrounds it also was
slightly wide-angle and I found out of
all of them the coloring was probably
the best now for the back camera no live
focus no portrait mode just point and
shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
in conclusion the camera that you have
with you will always be the best camera
cliche I know but it's the truth I'm
curious to find out from you guys in the
comments below what you guys thought was
the best out of each test that I did
I'll be looking out for those comments
in the meantime this is a time-lapse
from the new iPhone 8 plus with that
being said I am so excited for the
iPhone Ted baby
[Music]